you could describe the season finale of
game of thrones in one
word how would you describe that
[Music]
disappointing
disappointing no epic i don't know
one of those ones a [ __ ] nobody thought
of that
he's bringing all the dead people back
to life and they put
women and children in a crypt with all
the dead people
so craw tyrion
is smart but i guess not that smart
could you give us your
uh into the camera your facial
expressions what it was like reading the
the last episode for the first time what
it was like reading the last episode for
the first time like the different
stages you went through i mean it's
pretty much one stage
okay just
cool that's it kit
was really fine with it i was pissed i
was pissed that it wasn't me killing the
night king i could have i
would have i would have given you like
i'd bet you
thousands before we read the finals i
was like yeah it's definitely me
and then they lead you on that john's
chasing the night king
[ __ ] turns and sees jon coming for
him is this going to be an epic fight
no i don't feel so very comfortable
because i don't know where i belong
if i'm part of the actor or i am part of
the
stunt man
many times the stunts are joking with me
hey
i think you don't need to do nothing
sometimes i think
no it's not true king and she plunges
the dagger up through the night king's
armor and the night king shatters
action when you read the script for your
final episode
um oh i i was
uh i was really
pleased with that and are you
happy with how things ended yeah
best season ever
then i only knew up until the end of
season four
i think at that time or maybe a little
soon after that of
killing tywin my father yes and i
thought
where from where i start to doing that
was enough for me
to sign on yeah that's a brilliant
character arc
yeah and then it went somewhere else yes
all happy with the way you
think with the outcome of the show
alongside jon snow gendry is one of the
good guys in terms of the fact that
he has never asked for any of this
do you know what i mean and seeing him
kind of
being brought back into the fray it's a
little bit avengers assemble and it's a
little bit kind of like
well that was totally what season seven
was all about isn't it
exactly character development i love it
but it i really need to shut up you're
brave
were there actual like palpable moments
of of this cast and crew that last table
read like
i mean not to give anything away but i'm
assuming there's moments where you're
like of course
yeah it's going to be a terrible last
season
but i've just been like deadpan like
nothing happened yeah
there are no better writers in
television than dan weiss and david
benioff
they ended it brilliantly better than i
could have imagined
and uh
best of my name breaker of trains and
mother of dragons
you